I feel like I've known you'll I know you
a little bit more now I know the
upbringing your dad yeah yeah I mean how
you started that your journey um did
that thing that you just showed me with
me really kind of tripped me out a
little bit yeah that's yeah because you
know what I only did that week one time
and I really remember it really I don't
remember you yeah but I remember that
week we live in Vegas no no it was a my
friend's 21st birthday or something like
that oh so you weren't even you were
just used to happen to be there that's
yeah the reason why I was probably nice
to him is because of the fact that
somewhere along that week I was at a
Geraldine there's a Geraldine ease ice
cream place Ghirardelli Ghirardelli
apparently I don't like when people do
that I'm sorry because you guys know
what I was talking about
well not in I don't know uh well
actually he it didn't it didn't even
click in his head
only in my I'm gonna I was eating at a
live garden okay get it first gets a
point I was eating a baka depo boo boo
good about that yes there we go I mean
it's that some you're right I apologize
right I could do another one you know I
was at a Kiki's Coco's yes rockman I was
eating Atlantis - yeah yeah so what I'm
saying
is that it's easy to do if you try all
right yeah yeah is is you know a
sandwich the three of the morning at
railway subway yeah see what I mean
no cuz you so geraldine ease i said he
said Geraldine's whatever ice cream no
cuz they're going for chocolate byah to
you it was during the day and there was
all these like fat you know Middle
American Americans there's these
gigantic Sundays with knots on that
right people all great great people and
they're gonna influence our country in a
great way ya know they either it's don't
even get me started on that but um I
remember sitting there and dipping my
ice cream there and I remember biting in
it and go I'm gonna kill myself hmm
because that was right when when I had
that mohawk was right when after MADtv
right and then nothing nothing happening
in my career at that time yeah and I was
like I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do and also that gig you do 16
shells Monday through Monday Wow so
you're there from Monday through Sunday
right you do two shows a night and then
like on Friday you do a couple you do
extra on the weekends
yeah and they lose show regardless who's
in the audience so a Monday first show
is five people who got the coupon I
think you know got the track that put
the pack at the at the desk
oh there's a comedy show yeah that was
us who was that you guys got a comedy
show we never yeah yeah yeah so you know
it was the one a pump I was there you
know open for me Aron Kader ah and that
was one of the worst weeks of my life
and it's so interesting that he pulled
that up
because in my desperation there and in
my bottom I met a future kid and it's
it's all nosotros yeah yeah I think you
seem to me man
because it was like a negative week for
you but it ended up being positive and
that's another thing is that you could
be at your lowest mm-hmm but you don't
know who you're affecting oh yeah listen
to that yeah you know you could just be
like in a bad place and this and that
but you know you know when they say when
something bad happens they go well
there's a reach there might be a reason
yeah there there could be and you're his
catalyst you know or maybe I'm just like
talking out of my ass right now maybe
yeah you never know you know you we were
family now young man do you know that
blood brothers
excuse me blood brothers oh yeah
[Music]